who did this to you
where is he
what
no it's not
it's nothing
it's hot in here
yeah
thanks
i
you don't need to stay here i know
so you're pmsing pretty bad huh
dreams are just that their dreams they
help get you through the day
like the thing about the terrace it's
nice
but um i don't know it was just
something i read in this book when i was
12.
uh the girl in the book has a terrace
outside of her bedroom and she planted
flowers on it and i just loved that
just always kind of stuck with me
so you're not doing it
how did you know
why not
just like no big reason just a bunch of
little reasons
come on
roy's right there's no guarantee it's
going to lead to anything anyway
roy said that
what you have something you want to say
you got to take a chance on something
sometime pam
i mean do you want to be a receptionist
here always oh excuse me i'm fine with
my choices
you are
yeah
it's impractical
i'm not gonna
try to get a house like that
um they don't even make houses like that
in scranton
so i'm never gonna
just go along with it okay all right
just follow my lead don't pimp me all
right come in
so uh corporate just said that i don't
want to oh thank you pam pam can you
come in here for a sec
just have a seat i was gonna call you in
anyway um
you know ryan um
as you know
there's going to be downsizing and uh
you have made my life
so much easier
in that i am going to have to let you go
first what why
why well theft
and stealing
stealing
um
what am i supposed to have stolen
post-it notes
post-it notes yeah okay what are those
worth like 50 cents 50 cents yeah you
steal a thousand post-it notes at 50
cents a piece and you know you've made a
profit
margin you know go
run us out of business pam
are you serious
yeah i am
um
i can't believe this i mean i've never
even stolen as much as a paper clip and
now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
we're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh i just clean out
your desk i'm sorry
you've been ex-punk
surprise it's a joke we were joking
around
let's see
okay he was in on it he was my
accomplice and
there was just kind of a morale booster
thing and we were showing the new guy
around kind of
kind of giving him the feel of the place
so
you
god you were we totally got you're a
jerk
i don't know about that
can you figure out how to upload uh
cc's dance recital i definitely could
use a pick me up um actually funny story
i didn't get it i shouldn't have been so
cocky about my rectangle holding skills
after all you're not serious are you
you didn't get any of the recital
no i got the teacher introducing them
and then the applause afterwards but not
so much of the middle part come on pam
pam i asked you if you could use the
phone and you swore that you knew how
yeah okay i'm sorry
i'm sure we can get a copy a lot of
people were taping it oh great so we'll
see somebody else's kid with cece in the
background i mean
it's really not that hard to film a
video is there
i'm
you want to ease up a little bit look
pam i don't know what to tell you i mean
what do i do
it's gone that moment's just gone i
missed it i don't know jim maybe you
should have been there
you're not serious right
i mean how is that fair
i'm in philly these are my days in
philly you've agreed to this you know
what i i don't think you want to start a
conversation with me about what's fair
okay this is
way more intense than i ever i'm not
explaining this to pam i'm not going
over there again i don't know how
awesome we need you
i don't know what else to tell you okay
i'm doing everything i can every week to
bring home something for our friends i
am trying to make everything perfect
here okay so that you can have
everything that you want i'm doing this
just for me is that what i'm doing i'm
doing it just for me
if that's what you think then this is a
really sad night but you know what i
gotta go
okay
yep
we'll talk tomorrow
yep
i'll talk tomorrow
all right great i'll talk to you
tomorrow
bye
are you
okay am i doing wrong brian
nothing you're doing the best you can
ryan
never mind
it's just a tough situation all right
it's getting tougher
i just don't know that it's gonna be
this hard yeah
let's turn the cameras off seriously
guys
enough in us
thank you
[Music]
are you watching that commercial again
why do you keep watching it if you know
it's just gonna make you cry
because everything makes me cry so
what's the difference
this dog
he just wants to protect his bone
he's got a bank ball that's a star not
enough though
you